From the Library of Congress in
Washington DC
We've done two so far one on the Mapa Quetzalecatzin and one on the Oztoticpac
Lands Map and today we are going to
do the Huexotzinco Codex which as
Naomi said in the intro is one of the
top treasures here at the Library.
Today we're going to take a little bit
different tact on this the other two
codices that we looked at the Quetzalecatzin and the Oztoticpac Lands Map are
all one single sheet whereas the Huexotzinco Codex is eight sheets of amate
which is a mulberry fig bark paper a
typical indigenous paper from the Nahua
and it also has 79 pages of text
associated with it which basically
narrate a lawsuit and so we're going to
be looking both at the text and at the
actual codex themselves eight pages of
the Codex that are on amate are also
written in Nahuatl hieroglyphic
writing and we'll take a sort of deep
dive into that the Nahuatl hieroglyphs and
the sort of symbolism we see on those
pages but we have to first start out
kind of talking a little bit about about
the court case itself and we'll kind
of go into some details and it's going
to be like I said a little bit different
in format because I'm actually going to
read a little bit of the translations of
the some of the testimony and some of
the material from the the actual book
that the the eight pages were found in
just so we get a kind of flavor of what
what these types of Spanish lawsuits and
what these sort of Spanish law was as
they affected both the indigenous
peoples and and the early settlers the
Huexotcinzo Codex dates from 1531 1532
so it's a very very early post-colonial
codex. First though we're going to look a
little bit about what the paper is that
the these eight pages are on the other
two codices the Oztoticpac Lands Map is on amate, also the Quetzalecatzin
is on European paper and we
haven't really talked very much about
the paper at all and I thought I would
just take a couple minutes to talk a
little bit about about what the paper is
and and and how it's made and kind of
what it looks like. There are really a
couple of different kinds one made from
the ficus genus and there's several
different ficus species that are found
in Mexico and Central America and
this is a basically a fig tree. You'll
see here I've got just a botanical
specimen from the national herbarium and
then a picture of the actually the ficus
padifolia on the right and just really
what the kind of the paper looks like
when it's made on the left that's a
sample of a modern sample of the paper
made from the inner bark of the the
ficus tree and you can see it's very
dark very much like the Oztoticpac Lands
Map was that we looked at last time.
Today's codex, however, is on a much
lighter paper and this really probably
comes from the Morris genus which is the
mulberry and it gives a much lighter
paper again it's made from the inner
bark of the tree and it's still made in
Mexico today. The inner bark is pulled
off and then and then soaked it becomes
very very soft several things are added
to the the bath in order to soften it
and then it's basically smeared and
beaten and you can see here is an
indigenous paper maker making a sheet of
paper very much like we are going to be
looking at today when we're looking at
the Huexotzinco Codex. The Huexotzinco
Codex is on a paper that's almost white
and it's fairly thin but but a very
durable paper and this is a typical
paper making operation down in Mexico
today and here are some of the pieces of
paper and some of the various patterns
put in the paper that are out drying in
the sun after there they're put down
there they're laid out in the Sun and
then once they dry you can you can then
pick them up and there is
roughest paper and so the codices that we're going to be
looking at today are really this kind of
this kind of paper and so without
further ado we'll start talking a little
bit about the Codex so this is the first
page that the Codex actually what we
have here is we have a lawsuit and the
lawsuit is actually brought by Hernando
Cortes the the conqueror of Mexico one
of the first conquistadors to to arrive
there and a man named Marquis De Valle
and they're bringing up a suit against
several people a man named Nuno Guzman a
man named Juan Ortiz del Maritzio and a man
named Diego Delgadillo and basically
what is important about the codex's and
and what happens in this codex is you've
got 79 pages of Spanish text and in the
79 pages in Spanish text you have an or
narration of this court case and
basically you have some of the native
testimony, the indigenous testimony the
Nahua testimony in many cases refers
to the actual Nahuatl hieroglyphic texts
that we see here almost all of which
have to do with tribute and and and
price is paid for various species of
tribute slaves traded and things like
that and we'll get into that in just a
bit. The codex itself has an interesting
history. It was housed in the [inaudible] town
of the Immaculate Conception and Jesus
of Nazareth's in Mexico City for a very
long time and at some point it passed
directly to Cortes's descendants and those
are the Italian Dukes of Monteleone
and those Italian Dukes held the Codex
for a very long time along with a lot of
other Cortes materials and it remains in
this private archive until 1925 and it
was purchased by a man named Harkness in
through a really well-known dealer named
ASW Rosenbach. Rosenbach was an extremely
important rare book dealer and
manuscript dealer during the 1920s. The
Rosenwald collection--those of you who
are familiar with a large rare book
collection here at the Library--a lot of
those materials were also purchased
through Rosenbach. So the subject of
the of the lawsuit is really the sort of
misappropriation of funds and the way a
law case would work in a in a Spanish
court of this period is much different
than a law case would work in a law
court today really what would happen is
charges would be brought by some
plaintiff and the plaintiff would would
make up a questionnaire and really this
is actually a questionnaire which has a
series of questions which he would then
they would devise and then they would
give to their witnesses and their
witnesses would answer the questionnaire
for a scribe and the scribe would write
down the the the answers and so what we
have in this codex is actually Cortes's
side of this story. We have the information and the
questions that Cortes and his side is
putting to the Guzman side and so after
those questionnaires were done they
would be sent to the defendants the
answers be sent to the defendants the
defendants would be given a particular
span of time and they would produce
their own questionnaire which they would
then send to their witnesses. There'd be
another exchange of these back and forth
between the defendants and the
plaintiffs and those would go to a judge.
If the judge thought that the testimony
was complete enough he would render a
decision and if the the court case was
big enough, if there was enough money at
stake, it may have to go back to Spain as
opposed to being decided in Mexico City
but most of these local cases in the new
world were were decided in Mexico City.
But in this case we only have the one
side, we only have Cortes's documents in
the Codex here. Now what the codex begins
with it begins with a group of charges
and I'm just going to read a little bit
because I think it's important to kind
of get an idea of what the language is
and how the language sounds and
obviously this is a translation but but
I think it's an interesting way to kind
of take a look at about the way these
things were put forward and it begins
basically saying that this is a court
case against Nuno Guzman and several
other people who are in charge of the
area around Huexotzinco and it
begins saying, "I say that while my said
party held and possessed by just and
write titles and grant of your majesty
which justify and have justified the
possession use and utilization of the
Indians of the town of Huexotzinco
which is in the province," and then
there's a lacuna in the manuscript,
"taking the fruits in the profits of said
town the said Nuno de Guzman did in
fact and against alright and without any
cause or reason take from my said party
the said town and the utilization
thereof." So basically this has been
appropriated this town and the fruits of
the labors and the the the important
cash crops have been appropriated by
Nuno Guzman and it says continues, "and
they took in appropriated the said town
for themselves taking the fruits and
incomes of it as they have taken them
from the year 29 past to the present
making use of the said town in all the
enterprises they could as well as
services and other necessary things and
what is worse is that at the time when
they took the said town from my said
party they published and said that they
were placing it under tribute to your
majesty." And basically the
manuscript here literally says "placing
it in the head of your majesty" in order
to that they might make use of the
incomes and profits of the said town and
in truth your
Majesty has enjoyed the name and they
have taken for themselves and enjoyed
the profit and I think that's an
interesting little little thing there so
basically we have a group of people who
are now been accused of taking account
over which was basically given to the
indigenous people for tribute. They have
said that they were taking it,
placing the tribute under the crown and
giving it to the crown but in fact they
were keeping it to themselves and only
using the name of the crown to name name
only some things never change obviously.
And then it says "and since the laws of
your realm that is prohibited that
judges should make such users and carry
on such dealings and enterprises because
they must keep their hands clean in
everything the said Nuno de Guzman in
doing what they did committed violence
crime spoilation and notorious fraud
which in law is considered as a capital
case." And so that is really the
execution of the charges that begin the
codex and begin the Huexotzinco
Codex and so as I said according to
Spanish law the next part of the the
case here would be for the plaintiffs to
draw up some sort of questionnaire which
they did and in the case of the way of
single codex it's a multi-point question
here it actually has fourteen
independent questions and we're not
going to go into all of the questions
but there's one that's kind of important
for what we're going to see as we
actually go through the pages of the
codex themselves and it's actually
number four and what the number
four says it basically begins, "also
whether they know and have seen," and this
is put in the form of a question so this
is being asked to the witnesses, "whether
they know and have seen that as soon as
and then it names for defendants arrived
in the city they summon the Lords from
the leading men of the town and ask that
they give and bring a certain quality
more than six thousand pesos of gold
ingots and jewels and also stones and
feathers and clothing and slaves in an
amount worth more than another thousand
gold pesos
and let the witnesses say what
gold, stones, feathers, clothing slaves and
other things they gave to the said
president immediately upon their arrival
and on the road before they arrived in
the city." And so this is basically a
question asking witnesses that what kind
of tributes what sort of things were
given to Nuno de Guzman and the other
people by the leading men of the city
and whether these were these demands
made of gold and and other kinds of
tribute and what we're going to see
actually is when we begin looking at the
Codex pages here we're just going to be
seeing lists of tributes and lists of of
these kinds of items and we're going to
see that basically a lot of what we have
in the Codex itself is native testimony
is indigenous testimony and we're going
to look at one in particular because
right after that we'll get actually into
the Codex pages and one of the things
that the Huexotzinco Codex is famous
for is a small portrait of the Virgin
Mary considered to be the first portrait
of the Virgin Mary in the new world that
was actually rendered by an indigenous
person. What's interesting about that is
people believe that from how it was
rendered for a reason of being pious or
something like that or making the codex
somehow seem religious but in fact it's
a little bit different than that and
we'll see that in just a minute.
So I'm going to just read a couple more
little things and then we'll get into
the Codex themselves and I'm going to
read the testimony an answer to that
number four by an indigenous person
and that particular testimony begins it
says, "after the aforesaid
in the said City of Mexico on
Monday the third day of the month of
April in the year 1531 through an
interpreter Juan de [inaudible] this
citizen of the city a statement and
disposition was received from Esteban an
indigenous who was previously named
Toshell
which in the Christian language means
rabbit. From the said witness through the
said interpreter an oath was received
in do legal form under the obligation
which he promised to tell the truth and
what he said and deposed is the
following," and so that's the way his
testimony begins and I'm going to read
his answer to the fourth question and
then we're going to begin looking at the
Codex itself and so he says to the
fourth question he said that when Nino
Nuno de Guzman arrived in the city
the Indians of the said town Huexotzinco
and its province did not come to it nor
did they go out to receive them except
that the Lord and leading men of the
head Indians and this witness with them
came to the city to see and know them
and they did not bring them any gold or
cloth or anything else except they
brought food,
hens, quail--possibly as many as forty
hens and twenty quail--and a little
basket of eggs. And about a year after
Nuno de Guzman had come to the city the
overseer of the said town who is named de
Bahia who has reportedly gone to
Guatemala told them that they should
give something to Nuno de Guzman when he
wanted to go to the war. And they asked
what they should give and he told them
whatever they wished and they determined
to make cloth with a sheet of gold and
the whole sheet of gold would be an
image of Saint Mary this they gave to
the said Nuno de Guzman, they and said
overseer, and they brought it to him in
this city and for the workmanship and
expense of what the said image cost they
sold twenty slaves--eight men and
twelve women. And they also but for three
ingots of gold which went into the said
image on the top of a cloth on which the
image was placed there were nine plumages, each plumage consisting of twenty
feathers and these cost nine loads of
little awnings with twenty awnings in
each load and this witness saw that
Union to Guzman said to the Lord of
Huexotzinco that she he should give him men to go to
war with. Six hundred men outfitted for war
after the manner in which they were
accustomed to and they gave them and
with them also certain clothing in gear
which they have painted on certain
papers." Now we're beginning to talk about
the manuscript itself. "And he asked that
the said papers be shown to him and he
was shown one paper of certain paintings
which is signed with the sign of me the
undersigned notary and secretary. And when
he had looked at the pictures the said
interpreter said that in gear for the
said warriors they had spent thirty two
thousand and four hundred pieces of
cloth and small awnings
and then he corrected himself to say
that there were twenty seven thousand
and six hundred little awnings." And this
goes on basically talking about a whole
list of things that were given and cost
that were cost that were brought all to
go to war and all to make this image it
actually ends, "all this has been state
all this has been stated is painted on
the said paper on which the depicted the
said image of Our Lady and which is
signed with my sign." And so really what
we have here is we have this court case
where we have a whole slew of pages
which are going to talk about what we're
actually given to Guzman or
appropriated by him in order to go to
war or spent by the indigenous rulers of
Huexotzinco in order to make this gold
image of the Virgin Mary. And so really
that's what this codex is. So let's
let's get to the codex itself here and
we'll the codex the eight pages are
actually numbered and they're actually
numbered by the scribe who is actually
writing a little bit in in this book
name is Alonzo Valverde and he talks
about the testimony and he actually
signs the the images themselves and
so what we have here is we have the
beginnings of this testimony and we're
just going to go over some of the
symbolism here just because I think it's
kind of fascinating the way that these
things are put and you will begin to get
a sense of the huge number, the vast
array of tribute that was spent and
collected by this group of people in
order to make this image and and for
this going to war and so we'll look at
the manuscript here and we'll
begin and hopefully this won't drive
people too crazy I'm going to use the
little pointer to actually point out
some of the things on the manuscript
when we when we look at this one here we
see these two rings and these are
actually loads of lime and so we have
here two loads of lime that have
been put on on this sheet. B here is two
piles of adobe bricks for construction
this is people have called the chocolate
chip the chocolate chip tribute but this
is actually what we have here is we have
six and those little flags are twenty so
six times 20 loads or beams. Some things
we don't know exactly what they are over
the side this is kind of an unknown
group of things. This here is another
way of of doing 400 you've got seven
these things in this is actually
four hundred and so we have seven times
four hundred loads of cloths, so two
thousand eight hundred loads of cloth.
And then of course we know this is again
lime we have some stones here this part
here is again we've got the same number
so four hundred is this bundle and
this maize up here, so we've got two
thousand eight hundred loads of maize.
Down here with the little heads what
kind of bird does it remind you of well
of course it's a turkey and so we have
lots of lots of turkeys and so one
hundred and forty turkeys, seven times twenty.
This number down here in these little
boxes is a huge number and this is
actually eight thousand so we have two
times eight thousand or sixteen thousand
chili peppers that are also listed on
here. And really the codex continues this
way, again
more amounts of turkeys and maize.
We've got the chili peppers and so
this continues very much in this way and
this is talked about in the Spanish text
exactly where this is coming from and
what it's being used for. One of the most
striking pages in the entire codex is
this and what we have here is of course
you can see that the numbers in the
middle, those flags which you now know
are 20 and these are 20 cloths with
designs and there's basically several
different patterns there's a flower
design there's a rabbit design and
there's the design that looks like a
reed so we've got three different
different kinds of designs here and the
entire cost is we've got 37 times 20
which equals these cloths down here and
all total we've got about four hundred
and sixty flower patterns, 160 rabbit
patterns, and 120 reeds if one adds this
all up and so these are cloths that
are given in tribute that are
talked about the third page...the fourth
page I should say is this and this
is the most abstract of the
pieces and really what these are is
five cloths of rove woven red rabbit fur
and the total is 400 mantles. Four
times 20 equals 80 and then when you add
them all up you actually have 400
mantles
of woven red rabbit fur. Now we get to
the Virgin Mary page, the page which
the codex is probably most famous for
and that Esteban talks about in his
testimony and this is basically
listing what it cost in order to put the
the actual solid gold image of the
Virgin which is portrayed here together.
And up here we have this symbol here
this is four hundred pots of liquid
amber and so that's quite a thing, then
we've got this here is mantles of food,
four hundred mantles of food that one
purchases in route. See here, you can see
the feet this group right here there's
four and we now know of course this is
400 so for sixteen hundred pairs of
sandals are here and we can go on and
talking about this and then for instance
for this which is a banner for Don Tomei
to carry, it costs ten loads ten loads
with mantles there then we have three
gold plaques right here that are listed
used in the in the standard of the
Madonna in other words used to make the
Madonna itself. Here we've got plumages,
so twenty large green feathers and
we talked about the cost of that. This
here of course is the famous Madonna in
the middle for Nino Guzman and it is 16
by 16 inches of gold leaf and it's
supposed to be one of the earliest
productions related to Catholicism in
the New World by the indigenous peoples
and then here we've got 21 gold plaques
the thickness of three fingernails to
purchase a horse for Don Tomei the
principal and brother of Lord of
Huexotzinco. Here we have metal tip darts and the
group of metal tip darts here and then
loincloth along the bottom here and then
we have slaves, groups of slaves in order
to...who are sold to buy the Madonna and
this is an interesting little thing here,
we've got this group of slaves along the
bottom here and these slaves at least
according to the testimony were actually
sold to indigenous merchants to buy the
gold in order to make the Madonna and so
it's quite an interesting quite an
interesting page this figure which
people talk about so much. The next page
here these are two Aztec war leaders
with different shield designs. There's 11
houses basically who contributed to the
work so basically 11 different family
lineages who contributed warriors to
this supposed war effort that we were
talking about in the in the testimony
itself and then we we have the numbers
of warriors along here this basically
gives us four numbers of warriors and
then we have woven bags and then we have
blankets so again more about the same
same stuff, same source type of issues.
Again here we have another page this
time talking more about grain this is a
granary up here that we see so it's a an
indigenous granary holding maize which
was paid in 1529 and 1530 so just before
the the actual codex is made so the
events the codex is actually narrating
are between 1529 which is the date
that's given in the what I read the
initial charges that begins in 1529 and
we are in 1531 so this exploitation and
this taking out of money and
tribute in order to go to war by this
group of people
against Cortes or or stealing from
Cortes basically happens over a two-year
period. And so it gets more and more
complicated as the text goes
on there are about twenty to twenty-five
different testimonies from the
indigenous peoples within the thing
itself within the actual Codex itself
and that really does give us a real
sense of how these cases are narrated
and and really how important this was
when we start looking at some of the
numbers and adding up some of the
numbers, for instance when we look at
this number right here when we look at
this right here we basically have a
total of about eight thousand turkeys
here so it's a substantial, substantial
amount when we go down to this row down
here and we see the corn here we're
talking 32,000 ears of corn and here
we're talking about 48,000 chili peppers
so a lot of a lot of money that has been
exploited or misappropriated in Huexotzinco
by Nuno Guzman and the
others who are named in the case.
Unfortunately, I cannot tell you how the
case turned out and as I said we only
know really the one side of it. There are
some documents which give us hints to
the to the other side but they don't
give us much in the way of conclusive
evidence. It seems as if that this
particular codex survived mostly because
it went into the hands of Cortes's
descendants, the Dukes of Monteleone,
and that really is how it survived
and so I would be more than happy to
take any questions.
This has been a presentation of the
Library of Congress. Visit us at loc.gov.